Ah merde,
on n'a pas pris la bouteille en partant.
Excusez-moi Monsieur?
Oui ?
Vous connaissez pas un arabe,
pas loin?
Ouais, j'en vois un
vraiment pas loin là.
Ah ouais,
où?
Ben, vous voyez pas?
Non, où?
Ben là, à deux pas.
Non mais si vous savez pas,
dites-le, c'est pas grave.
Ah ben tiens,
si vous cherchez un Indien,
lui il va sûrement pouvoir vous aider.
Non mais on a déjà mangé nous.
On veut un arabe.
Bon ben si vous voyez pas,
je peux pas vous aider.
Pff, tous les mêmes.
-Tous les mêmes qui?
Ben vous!
-Non mais «vous» qui?
Dites-le moi, j'ai l'habitude,
vous allez pas me vexer.
Ben vous, les parisiens
à pas nous aider là.
C'est un peu cliché
mais vous êtes pas sympa.
Bon euh,
reprenons à zéro, ok?
Je me présente, je m'appelle
Akim Lounes Achour.
Et vous cherchez?
Un arabe.
Vous l'avez ou pas?
Bon, laissez tombé, c'est sur ma route,
vous me suivez.
C'est là.
-Merci!
Ah putain c'est super dur
de trouver un arabe dans le coin.
Hamdoulilah,
moi, je suis là!